this morning diving into an ancient
civilization to learn more about
discoveries helping our modern world
it's all thanks to an American husband
and wife team sharing a love story and
lifetime commitment to explore the Mayan
civilization dates back as far as a
thousand BC or earlier their territory
covered about a hundred and twenty
thousand square miles in Central America
that includes Belize where Jeff Gore
traveled to Caracol the site of the
largest Mayan city ever discovered many
of its Secrets haven't been revealed
until recently using technology that
shows how Mayans built the kinds of
cities we aspire to today 2 000 years
ago
what is this
that particular building we call Kana or
sky place we don't know what the Maya
called it but it seemed like a fitting
name to the first team of of belizeians
and us that were here so they got their
cardio in yeah
for sure
this is only part one
so it's part one and part two no there's
three oh lovely the highest structure in
the country of Belize put the Mayans of
Caracol on top of their Known World this
is uh one of my favorite places on site
and you can see everything from here and
everything you can see is car call so 40
years ago what did this look like when
you first arrived it looked like a hill
there was no architecture visible here
at all Diane Chase and her husband Arlen
have devoted their professional lives to
piecing together the uncovered remains
of A Lost Civilization car Cole was a
completely unknown city until 1937. and
when I first was introduced to the Mayan
High School I realized essentially how
little we knew about them based on our
section we know that there's plenty of
room out front here for another tomb the
chases have been coming here since
1985. Excavating over 400 buildings and
uncovering hundreds of thousands of
artifacts and there are two plates here
one bowl with some little things in it
and the skull for the first 24 years
they relied on traditional
archaeological techniques
that all changed in 2009 when they tried
a revolutionary technology called lidar
an Airborne laser mapping system that
can see through trees revealing hidden
spots that might have taken decades to
find otherwise
the Chase's son Adrian gave us a
demonstration this is what the flight
initially recorded and you can see all
of the trees in the forest canopy right
but I've angled it so it's along the
road you guys took in and earlier today
when you were walking let's get it to
rotate you went up Kana
this is kanaah here and I can remove
all the trees and show you that sort of
bare Earth model wow so you can see Kana
on this downtown wow but you can get a
sense of these different structures on
the landscape when we saw the results of
lidar it was phenomenal because all of a
sudden we had control of space we could
see where the structures were and where
they were not underneath these trees and
it it is equivalent in our minds to
radiocarbon dating radiocarbon dating
gave us control of time lidar could gave
us control of space in my area what do
you think the Mayans can teach us today
if you look at how Car Coal is built it
is it's an incredible planned city I
think we could learn something for the
plant it's a walkable City it's a green
City the reservoirs are are located so
that folks have access their fields near
almost every house in addition to that
everyone can get to a market so you can
see
um that it's actually lined on one side
and there's a walled group here inside
that seem to be some of the Artisans
that would have would have worked at the
site on the afternoon of our visits we
joined the chase team on a dig so we're
going to go to what we call a plazuela
group If This Were A
contemporary City you might say it was a
suburb at one of the sites they
discovered with that mapping technology
this excavation has been going on for a
little bit
we're looking for architecture
we're looking for a sequence of floors
so that's a front step
down there is bedrock
and we're Excavating to see you know how
many levels of occupation there are so
how do you how do you dig all this
by hand
by hand yeah because it's important same
way they built it yes
lucky for us we arrived just as a
Priceless artifact was Unearthed
thank you Carlos very good
it's pretty unusual to find whole things
here the the soil is I mean it's cracked
so it's you know it's it's not perfect
but uh usually we find things in pieces
so it's nice to find something that's
completely old how old is that this pot
yes uh what would you say Arlen 700 700
to 720. yeah that's 700 A.D or 1300
years old why did Mayan civilization
collapse
we have a view that it probably would
collapse because economics just like
we're having issues in the U.S over
globalization and importing products to
Maya in the late classic period we're
having the same kinds of issues what we
see in the late classic period is
everything's being imported into caracal
and probably for up to five generations
of people so if you have uh the system
is disrupted somewhere that's going to
have severe repercussions because nobody
remembers how to do things however go
ahead we see differences in the sort of
social status levels in the earlier part
of caracol's History their haves and
have-nots and then in the late classic
period what happens is everybody has
access to everything and then what
happens at the end of the classic period
right before the collapse you get the
one percent and then the Haves and the
have-nots again too two thousand years
of Mayan civilization is a pretty
impressive run
so is 40 Years of teamwork you like the
fact that we finish each other's
sentences that is exactly what I was
just going to say yeah and we do that
all the time you complete each other
we we work together really well some
people say how can you work with your
husband or how can you work with your
wife I think not knowing us of course
um and we are a good team
good
I love them I wonder they've just been
spending so much time in the jungle if
they even got the Jerry Maguire
reference they complete me I mean they
complete each other I love that and and
just the work it's so meaningful oh it
is to pull something out that is what
that bowl 1300 years old that
Civilization gave us mathematics a sense
of the sky it's truly fascinating the
more we learn about it and now we know
they were true city planners the fact
that they had suburbs and try to plan
out so you could walk to a market I mean
isn't that the mark of a great
neighborhood these days yes it certainly
is yeah we live in them too